FACING SOME BACKLASH AFTER A NEW
GRASSROOTS PUSH TO GET MORE
AMERICANS VACCINATED.
THIS COMES AFTER THE MORE
CONTAGIOUS DELTA VARIANT HAS
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES.
>> President Biden: WE NEED TO
GO FROM COMMUNITY TO COMMUNITY
AND KNOCK ON DOORS TO GET HELP
TO PEOPLE AND PROTECT THEM FROM
THE VIRUS.
>> Dana: AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
"PANIC ATTACKS."
WHEN I HEARD THAT, I THOUGHT HE
IS TRYING TO GIVE IT A SHOT TO
GET PEOPLE MORE INFORMATION.
WHY THE BACKLASH?
>> THE PRESIDENT FOUND HIMSELF
IN A BIT OF A DICHOTOMY DURING
THAT SPEECH.
HE WAS DECLARING INDEPENDENCE
FROM THE VIRUS, AND HE IS RIGHT.
AMERICANS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CHOOSE TO BE VACCINATED TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
LOVED ONES, BUT DECLARING THAT
INDEPENDENCE DOESN’T MEAN THE
PANDEMIC IS OVER.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE SAYS WE ARE
GOING TO SEND IT LOW LEVEL
GOVERNMENT WORKERS TO YOUR
HOUSE.
WHILE SOME PEOPLE MAY SEE THIS
AS A PUBLIC EDUCATION PAGE,
WHICH IS ALWAYS A GOOD THING,
THE MORE EDUCATION THE BETTER,
OTHERS MAY SEE THIS AS
CONFRONTATIONAL.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT IS NOT HOW
YOU ARE GOING TO REACH THAT
VACCINE HAS ATTENDED POPULATION.
THEY ARE GOING TO ALREADY FEEL
THAT YOU ARE INVADING THEIR
SPACE.
>> Dana: DR. NICOLE, LISTEN TO
THIS.
"HOW ABOUT IT DON’T KNOCK ON MY
DOOR.
YOU ARE NOT MY PARENTS.
YOU ARE THE GOVERNMENT.
WHY IS THAT CONCEPT SO HARD FOR
THE LEFT?"
IN "THE WASHINGTON POST," IT
ALSO SAID IN MARYLAND 100 PEOPLE
DIED OF COVID ENGINE.
100% OF THEM WERE UNVACCINATED.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS TRYING TO SAY
YESTERDAY, I SUPPOSE.
>> THAT IS NOT JUST MARYLAND.
THAT IS MANY STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THE DEBTS THAT ARE STILL
OCCURRING TEND TO BE THOSE THAT
ARE UNVACCINATED.
THE BEST WAY TO PROTECT PEOPLE
IS TO GET VACCINATED.
AGAIN, THIS IS FREEDOM OF
CHOICE.
THAT IS WHAT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
IT GOES TO THE CORE OF OUR
COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU TURN ON OTHER MEDIA
OUTLETS, YOU HEAR PEOPLE CALLING
FOR REQUIRING THEM AND MANDATES.
YOU CAN’T DECLARE INDEPENDENCE
AND THE FREEDOM TO CHOOSE
VACCINATION, AND THEN REQUIRE
THEM AS WELL.
THESE ARE CONVERSATIONS THAT
NEED TO BE HAD BETWEEN
PHYSICIANS AND PATIENTS, AND NOT
BY LOW-LEVEL PEOPLE PEOPLE
KNOCKING ON DOORS.
>> Dana: IT HAS BEEN BUILDING,
BUT A LOT OF THE HEADLINES ARE
TARGETED AND BLAMING ANYONE WHO
VOTED FOR TRUMP OR THE RED
STATES.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE THE
PROBLEM.
A LOT OF THOSE PLACES ARE
BRUTAL.
SOME OF THEM DON’T HAVE THAT
FANCY FREEZERS THAT CAN TAKE THE
PFIZER OR MATURING OF VACCINES.
HOW WOULD YOU PERSUADE SOMEONE
TO GET THE VACCINE?
>> THERE IS A LOT OF POLITICIZED
NATION THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
COURSE OF THE VACCINATION, BUT
THE BEST THING THAT THE CDC AND
THE ADMINISTRATION COULD DO IS
TO REACH OUT TO THOSE HESITANCE.
THAT HAS TO DO WITH GETTING FULL
FDA APPROVAL.
I THINK IT WILL HELP PEOPLE
TRUST THE SAFETY MORE IF THEY
GET THAT FULL APPROVAL.
THEY NEED TO BE TRANSPARENT.
THEY CAN’T BE SO MYOPIC WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ADOLESCENT
RECOMMENDATIONS, ESPECIALLY AS
WE SEE RISING CASES OF
MYOCARDITIS.
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO NEGLECT
NATURAL IMMUNITY, AND THEY
CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND PHIL DOES
FOR ADOLESCENTS REGARDLESS OF
RISK AND REGARDLESS OF PRESENCE
OF NATURAL IMMUNITY.
IF THEY DID THAT, I THINK THEY
WOULD GAIN THE TRUST OF AMERICAN
PEOPLE MORE.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
TRUST.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE IT IS
AVAILABLE TO THE RURAL
POPULATION, AND YOU HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
EDUCATION.
THE WAY TO DO THAT IS TO REACH
OUT TO LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH